tell me about how you enjoy bringing
this 60s period to life on the big
screen is fabulous it was so much fun
and to actually tell the story that
comes from a place that is real that
comes from the heart that is celebrating
for indigenous women in the community
who are your two your two women it's
really wonderful that we get the
opportunity to do this yeah and not to
mention the hair and makeup you know
these are when you meet the auntie's in
real life there's so glamorous right up
until today
so I can only imagine how much fun they
had in the sixties yeah being these
amazing yada yada women just yeah it's
very privileged how much temptation is
there to try and keep some of the
dresses and things afterwards I'm not uh
sorry I'm not a prop girl so that I was
happy to give them back I did actually
keep a couple I got to keep a couple but
all the performance numbers are
somewhere in archives I think look as
though tailored for us and Tess who's
was our costume designer she tried to
source the most authentic fabrics of
that era so it was really beautiful to
wear them how important is he you to be
a kind of inspiration for other
indigenous actresses as well out there
cuz of course it's such an important
role isn't it for you playing on the big
screen oh look it's a great great
responsibility that we can do this and
then I feel very proud that I can stand
here in London with a film like this
like it's beautiful absolutely uh Deb
was actually one of my inspirations
growing up so ii feel like now Miranda
and I have this path the way we can be
that to other young girls is just out of
this world
you